This episode is brought to you by Tellus Online Security. Oh, tax season is the worst. You mean hack season? Sorry, what? Yeah, cybercriminals love tax forms. But I've got Tellus Online Security. It helps protect against identity theft and financial fraud so I can stress less during tax season or any season.
本期节目由Tellus在线安全公司赞助。噢，报税季真是太糟糕了。你是说黑客季？抱歉，你说什么？是的，网络犯罪分子最喜欢报税表了。但我有Tellus在线安全服务。它能帮助抵御身份盗窃和金融欺诈，让我在报税季或任何时候都能少操点心。
Plans start at just $12 a month. Learn more at tellus.com slash online security. No one can prevent all cybercrime or identity theft. Conditions apply. With her lovely white skin and long hair, Tomouet had enchanting looks. An archer of rare strength, a powerful warrior, and on foot or on horseback, a swordsman to face any demon or God. She was a fighter to stand alone against a thousand. She could ride the wildest horse down the steepest slope.
套餐每月仅需12美元起。欲了解更多信息，请访问tellus.com斜杠online security。没有人能预防所有的网络犯罪或身份盗窃。适用相关条款。巴御前皮肤白皙，长发飘飘，容貌迷人。她是一位力量罕见的弓箭手，一位强大的战士，无论步行还是骑马，她都是一位能面对任何恶魔或神灵的剑客。她是一位能独自对抗千军万马的斗士。她能骑着最狂野的马从最陡峭的斜坡上冲下。
In battle, Kiso clad her in the finest armor, equipped her with a great sword and a mighty bow, and charged her with the attack on the opposing commander, she won such repeated glory that none could stand beside her. So that's one of the most celebrated descriptions of a samurai ever written. It comes from the tale of the Hekei, which introduces the character of Tomoe Gozen, Lady Tomoe, the archetype of a female warrior. So Tom Holland, who is Tomoe?
在战斗中，木曾为她穿上最好的盔甲，配备大剑和强弓，并让她负责攻击敌方指挥官，她屡获殊荣，无人能及。这大概是历史上关于武士最著名的描述之一。它出自《平家物语》，书中介绍了巴御前这一角色，即巴夫人，她是女性武士的原型。那么，汤姆·霍兰，巴御前是谁？
And what is she doing in battle with Lord Kiso, who is the mighty warlord, whose exploits dominated the last episode of this tremendous epic series about the great civil war of the samurai? I think before we come to Tomoe, we should just remind listeners of where we are in the sweeping epic that is the samurai civil war. So, Lord Kiso, mentioned in the passage that you read, He belongs to the Minamoto, who are one of the two great clans in 12th century Japan. And in the previous episode, we heard how he annihilated two armies that had been sent against him by the Tyra, who are the great dynastic rivals of the Minamoto. Kiso advanced on Kyoto, the imperial capital.
她在与木曾大人并肩作战时在做什么？木曾大人是那位强大的军阀，他的事迹主导了上一集关于武士伟大内战的史诗系列。我想在我们谈到巴御前之前，我们应该先提醒听众，我们正处于武士内战这一宏大史诗的哪个阶段。所以，木曾大人，也就是你读到的那段文字中提到的，他属于源氏，是12世纪日本两大氏族之一。在上一集中，我们听到了他是如何歼灭平氏派来对付他的两支军队的，平氏是源氏伟大的王朝竞争对手。木曾向京都，即帝国首都进军。
He expelled the Tyra and he took it over himself. But in doing this, he provoked the jealousy of his cousin, the scheming and ruthless and politically visionary head of the Minamoto clan Yoritomo, the warlord of a port, very near what today is Tokyo called Kamakura. And Yorotomo, very cross that Kiso, his cousin is threatening to upstage him, had sent his two younger half-brothers to lead a two-pronged attack on Kyoto. And their mission was effectively to destroy Kiso and to bring Kyoto under the control of Yoritomo. And the elder of these two half-brothers, a guy called Nori Yori, had advanced on Kyoto from the east. And the younger half-brother, the very dashing, Yoshitsune, had advanced from the south.
他驱逐了平氏，并亲自接管了京都。但这样做引起了他表弟的嫉妒，那位阴险、冷酷且具有政治远见的源氏族长——赖朝，他是今天东京附近一个港口城市镰仓的军阀。赖朝非常生气，因为他的表弟木曾威胁要抢他的风头，于是派他两个同父异母的弟弟率领两路大军进攻京都。他们的任务实际上是消灭木曾，并将京都置于赖朝的控制之下。这两个同父异母弟弟中，年长的一位叫范赖，他从东面进攻京都。而年轻的一位，非常潇洒的义经，则从南面进攻。
And it was Yershitsunei, even more dashing, even more daring, even more charismatic than the great Lord Kiso, who had reached Kyoto first in the late winter of 1184. And we ended our last episode by hearing how his priority, when he was. he arrived in Kyoto was to seize control of a key figure in the war. And this was the cloistered emperor, go Shirakawa, which means he had been emperor, he had abdicated, he was now officially a monk, but effectively he is the head of the imperial family. And he's a great schemer. He's not, he doesn't command armies himself. And so he's always trying to kind of play the various samurai warlords against one another. And he'd been able to do this because, although the state is now clearly
正是义经，比伟大的木曾大人更潇洒、更勇敢、更有魅力，他在1184年冬末率先抵达了京都。我们在上一集的结尾听到，当他抵达京都时，他的首要任务是夺取战争中的关键人物的控制权。这就是后白河法皇，这意味着他曾是天皇，后来退位，现在正式成为一名僧侣，但实际上他是皇室的领袖。他是一位伟大的阴谋家。他自己并不指挥军队。所以他总是试图让各路武士军阀相互对抗。他之所以能做到这一点，是因为虽然国家现在显然
under the thumb of the samurai dynasties, the first the Tyra and then the Minamoto, the notion of a samurai ruling the empire is still a massive novelty. And so all these various warlords who are marching into Kyoto, trying to seize control of it, trying to proclaim their supremacy over the rule of Japan, they still need the legitimacy that the backing of Gosherakawa, this cloistered emperor, can provide. And so this was why Kiso, while he had been in command of Kyoto, had been keeping Gosherakawa effectively under house arrest. And it's why Yoshitsunei, by capturing him alive, by seizing him from Kiso's control, can feel that a key objective has been obtained. You know, this was his great mission.
处于武士王朝的控制之下，先是平氏，然后是源氏，但武士统治帝国的概念仍然是一个巨大的新鲜事物。因此，所有这些进入京都、试图夺取控制权、试图宣布自己对日本统治权的军阀，仍然需要后白河法皇的支持所能提供的合法性。这就是为什么木曾虽然在指挥京都，却一直有效地将后白河软禁起来。这也是为什么义经通过活捉他，通过将他从木曾的控制中夺走，能够感觉到一个关键目标已经实现。你知道，这就是他伟大的使命。
He had to siege Kyoto, but he also had to seize Gosherakawa. So that's Yoshitsune. But what about Yoshitsune's older brother, Yoritomo, who is effectively the kind of the head, isn't he, of the Minamoto clan? Yeah, and who is still in his capital of Kamakura, which is adjacent to what today is the great bay on which Tokyo is built. Right. So he's been there all this time just waiting for the.
他必须围攻京都，但他还必须夺取后白河。这就是义经。但义经的哥哥赖朝呢，他实际上是源氏的族长，不是吗？是的，他仍然在他的镰仓大本营，就在今天东京所在的那个大湾区旁边。没错。所以他一直待在那里，基本上是在等待……
results, basically, waiting for news. He has no official constitutional position within the state. He is the head of the Minamoto, but that effectively just means that he's a samurai warlord. But what he can now do, now that Gosherakawa is in his younger brother's hands, is that he can lean on Gosherakawa to kind of dress him in the robes of constitutional propriety, to give him an official status within the fabric of the empire. and Yorotomo's growing dominance of Japan can then be presented to the court, to the Japanese people more generally, as something that is much less unsettling than it might otherwise appear. Effectively, his supremacy can be presented as something that has both the blessing and the approval of the imperial palace.
结果，基本上是在等待消息。他在国家体制内没有任何正式的宪法地位。他是源氏的族长，但这实际上只意味着他是一个武士军阀。但现在他能做的是，既然后白河在他弟弟手中，他就可以依靠后白河来为他披上宪法正当性的外衣，在帝国结构中赋予他官方地位。赖朝对日本日益增长的统治力，随后就可以呈现给朝廷，呈现给更广泛的日本民众，作为一种比原本看起来要少得多令人不安的事情。实际上，他的霸权可以被呈现为既得到了皇宫的祝福，也得到了皇宫的认可。
And so that was why it was so important for your Shitsune to get control of the cloistered emperor. Now there's another contender, of course, for supremacy, and that is this guy, Kiso, who dominated so much of the last episode. So he's now lost control of the cloistered emperor, Gosurakawa. And his plan had been that he would seize him and then he'd go off and he's effectively some sort of war at the kingmaker figure where he was going to end up allied to his old enemies, the Tyra. Now what does he do?
这就是为什么义经夺取法皇的控制权如此重要。当然，现在还有另一个争夺霸权的人，那就是木曾，他在上一集中占据了很大篇幅。所以他现在失去了对后白河法皇的控制。他的计划本是夺取他，然后离开，他实际上是某种战争中的造王者，他最终会与他的老敌人平氏结盟。现在他该怎么办？
Because he doesn't have control of the cloistered emperor anymore. So what's his plan? Yeah, so the cloistered emperor was going to, be his kind of bargaining chip. Yes, of course. But that's gone. So instead of fighting his way out of Kyoto and heading westwards to where the Tyra are, he heads eastwards.
因为他不再控制法皇了。那么他的计划是什么？是的，法皇本应是他的某种筹码。是的，当然。但那已经没了。所以他没有杀出京都向西前往平氏所在的地方，而是向东进发。
And the reason that he's doing that is that in the east, he has sent his beloved foster brother, a guy called Ime Kanahira, to hold back the advance of the Minamoto forces under Noriori, who is the elder brother of Yoshitsune. Kiso's forces are outnumbered, the situation is desperate. And as Kiso rides from Kyoto heading towards this bridge that, that him out Kinahera had been defending, he finds that enemy forces are everywhere. And so the war band that is riding with him sustain more and more casualties as they head east. And in the tale of the Heke, the writer reflects on the scale of Kiso's downfall.
他这样做的原因是，在东部，他派了他心爱的义弟，一个叫今井兼平的人，去阻挡范赖（义经的哥哥）率领的源氏军队的推进。木曾的军队人数处于劣势，局势绝望。当木曾从京都骑马前往今井兼平一直在防守的那座桥时，他发现敌军无处不在。因此，随着他们向东进发，与他同行的武士团遭受了越来越多的伤亡。在《平家物语》中，作者反思了木曾垮台的规模。
Only last year he had left Shinano, his great stronghold, leading an army of 50,000. and now passing the brook at Shinomia, he had only six riders with him. But one of those riders is the person with whom we began the episode, Tomoei, the female samurai. Yes. So that's a tremendous boon for Kiso. So who is she? She's quite a mysterious figure. She's very famous, but she's also very enigmatic and perhaps the two are connected.
就在去年，他离开了他伟大的据点信浓，率领着五万大军。而现在经过篠原的溪流时，他身边只剩下六名骑兵。但其中一名骑兵就是我们在本集开头提到的巴御前，那位女武士。是的。这对木曾来说是一个巨大的助力。那么她是谁？她是一个相当神秘的人物。她非常出名，但她也非常令人费解，也许这两者是相关的。
So according to the tale of the haiki, she was one of two beauties, quote unquote, brought by Kiso from Shinano, his mother. mountainous stronghold to Kyoto. And one of these women was called Yamabuki, and she was unwell at the point when Kiso had to abandon Kyoto, and so she had stayed in the capital. But Tomoei is fighting fit, literally so, and she rides with Kiso, and she proves herself on this kind of terrible journey that they're all taking, a much more proficient, a much tougher samurai than most of her male companions. So again, to quote the tale of the Hakey, this is why when so many had already been cut down in their flight, Tomaway remained among the last seven.
根据《平家物语》，她是木曾从信浓的山区据点带到京都的两位“美女”之一。其中一位女性叫山吹，在木曾不得不放弃京都时，她身体不适，所以留在了京城。但巴御前战斗力十足，确实如此，她与木曾并肩作战，在这段他们所有人都在经历的可怕旅程中，她证明了自己比大多数男性同伴更精通、更强悍。所以，再次引用《平家物语》，这就是为什么在逃亡中许多人已经被砍倒时，巴御前依然留在最后的七人之中。
So that's Kiso and his six companions. So eastwards they ride, and they're riding towards Lake Bewa, which is this enormous lake east of Kyoto, and there's a kind of river at the bottom of it. And that's where the bridge that Ima Kenahira had been defending against the advance of Noriori and his Minamoto army. But five hours after leaving Kyoto, they're approaching the shores of Lake Beahoe. and Kiso sees a band of 50 horsemen riding towards him. And this band is led by Ime, his foster brother, who has retreated from the bridge, kind of overwhelmed by the sheer weight of enemy numbers, and has been hoping to rendezvous with Kiso. And Kiso orders Ime to unfurl his banner, the great fluttering banner of Lord Kiso,
这就是木曾和他的六名同伴。他们向东骑行，正朝着琵琶湖骑去，那是京都东部的一个巨大湖泊，湖底有一条河。那就是今井兼平一直在防守，抵御范赖及其源氏军队推进的那座桥。但在离开京都五小时后，他们接近了琵琶湖岸边，木曾看到一队50人的骑兵正向他骑来。这支队伍由他的义弟今井率领，他从桥上撤退，被敌人的绝对数量优势所压倒，一直希望能与木曾会合。木曾命令今井展开他的旗帜，木曾大人那面巨大的飘扬旗帜，
and the sight of it raised up rallies his scattered supporters, and some 300 samurai, all of them loyal to Kiso end up gathered beneath it. But the problem is, is that the site of this banner, as well as attracting Kiso's samurai, also attracts the enemy. And they are coming in their thousands. Kiso leads a doomed charge against them. And he and some 50 men managed to break through, but then they find that there's another enemy warband waiting ahead of them. And again, to quote the tale of the heke, they broke through that too and further on through 500, through 150, then 100, each time at a cost until Kiso had only four left. And one of these four companions was Ime and another was Tomouet.
旗帜升起的那一刻，振奋了他分散的支持者，大约300名忠于木曾的武士最终聚集在旗帜下。但问题是，这面旗帜的出现，在吸引木曾武士的同时，也吸引了敌人。他们成千上万地涌来。木曾对他们发动了一次注定失败的冲锋。他和大约50人成功突围，但随后他们发现前方还有另一支敌军武士团在等着他们。再次引用《平家物语》，他们也突破了那道防线，随后又突破了500人、150人，然后是100人，每一次都付出了代价，直到木曾只剩下四个人。这四名同伴中，一个是今井，另一个是巴御前。
So she is still going strong. And Kiso, I'm afraid very ungallantly, orders her to go. He says, it must not be said that at the end I had a woman with me. So he doesn't order her to go for her own safety. It's for his reputation. His honour. He doesn't want to be said that he died in the presence of a woman. She refuses to go.
所以她依然战斗力强劲。而木曾，恐怕非常不绅士地命令她离开。他说：“不能让人说我最后身边竟然带着一个女人。”所以他命令她离开并不是为了她自己的安全。这是为了他的名声。他的荣誉。他不希望人们说他死的时候身边有一个女人。她拒绝离开。
She says, no, I'm standing by you. And then abruptly, they run into an enemy war band now of some 30 men. And this is led by a samurai who is famed for his strength, we're told. And Tomoehue recognises that this is the end game. And so she charges this samurai captain, the guy who's famed for his strength. And we're told, she caught him in an iron grip, forced his head down to her pommel, kept it pin there, twisted it round, cut it off, and tossed it away. And then she abandoned her arms and armour and fled toward the east.
她说：“不，我要和你在一起。”然后突然间，他们撞上了一支约30人的敌军武士团。这支队伍由一位以力量著称的武士率领。巴御前意识到这是最后的决战了。于是她冲向这位武士队长，那位以力量著称的人。书中写道，她用铁钳般的握力抓住了他，强行将他的头按到马鞍前，将其固定在那里，扭转它，砍下它，然后把它扔掉。随后她丢弃了武器和盔甲，向东逃去。
And we talked, I think, in our second episode about how this head hunting, that it's a kind of process of butchery. It's not a neat slicing. It's a hacking and a carving. And you really get the sense of that. And what of Kiso? So surely, you know, this is the end game for him, isn't it? And Ime, his brother knows it. Yeah.
我想我们在第二集中谈到过这种猎头行为，这是一种屠宰过程。这不是整齐的切割。这是砍伐和雕刻。你真的能感觉到这一点。那木曾呢？所以肯定，你知道，这是他的终局，不是吗？他的兄弟今井也知道这一点。是的。
So he, Emma points to a nearby clump of trees. And these are the pine wood of Awazoo. And Ime says to his foster brother, go in among those pines and take your life. So in other words, commit sepuku. And Kiso is reluctant because he wants to die by his foster brother's side. He says, I fled all the way here to die with you. I want us to die together, not apart. And saying this, he rides up beside I may on his horse and he says, come on, let's have a charge.
所以他，今井指着附近的一丛树木。那是粟津的松林。今井对他的义弟说：“进入那些松树林中，结束你的生命。”换句话说，切腹。木曾很不情愿，因为他想死在义弟身边。他说：“我一路逃到这里就是为了和你一起死。我要我们死在一起，而不是分开。”说完，他骑马来到今井身边，说：“来吧，让我们冲锋一次。”
Let's die in glory. But I may is absolutely insistent. It says, you know, I don't want you dying like this. I want you to have the dignity of your suicide. And so finally, Kiso kind of says, okay, fine. And he sets off at full gallop for this pine wood in the distance. But the light was failing and thin ice spread across the surrounding paddies.
“让我们光荣地死去。”但今井非常坚持。他说：“你知道，我不希望你这样死去。我希望你保持自杀的尊严。”所以最后，木曾说：“好吧，好吧。”他全速向远处的松林疾驰而去。但天色渐暗，薄冰覆盖了周围的稻田。
And Kiso's horse plunges up to its waist in mud, and it's immovable. No stirrup, no whip could move it. And Kiso looks back. He's very worried for him. And as he does so, his helmet tilts back. It kind of rocks back off his forehead. And at once, an enemy archer's arrow embeds itself there, splats straight into his forehead.
木曾的马陷入泥中直到腰部，动弹不得。没有马镫，没有鞭子能让它移动。木曾回头看。他非常担心今井。就在这时，他的头盔向后倾斜。它从他的前额滑落。立刻，一支敌方弓箭手的箭射中了那里，直接扎进了他的前额。
The wound was mortal. Kiso slumped forward onto his horse's neck. And two servants of the samurai who had shot him, this is a samurai called Ishida no Jiro Tamihisa. They cut off Kiso's head and they present it to their master. And Ishida is triumphant and he draws out his sword from his belt, sticks it on the tip, lifts it up high and he cries it. out in triumph. Lord Kiso, famed throughout Japan, has fallen to Eshida no Jiro Tamahisa. So again, this boasting about ancestry, which is such a feature of samurai bragadachio. Anime, he sees what's happened, and he gives up the fight, and we're told he took the point of his sword in his mouth, hurled himself headlong from his horse, and died transfixed.
伤口是致命的。木曾向前瘫倒在马脖子上。射杀他的那名武士（此人叫石田次郎为久）的两名仆人砍下了木曾的头，并将其呈献给他们的主人。石田得意洋洋，他从腰间拔出剑，将头颅插在剑尖上，高高举起，大声喊道。他得意地喊道：“名震日本的木曾大人，死于石田次郎为久之手。”再次强调，这种吹嘘血统的行为，是武士虚张声势的一个特征。今井看到了发生的一切，他放弃了战斗，书中写道，他将剑尖含在嘴里，从马上纵身跃下，贯穿而死。
So not exactly a sepucco, but, I mean, a spectacular suicide nevertheless. And so it came to pass, we're told that no battle took place at Awazoo. And this story, I mean, this is attested. There's no reason to doubt that this happened. I think the outline of it. Yeah, because this feels like the stuff of poetry, doesn't it? It feels like the stuff that might have been embroidered over time. For sure.
所以这不完全是切腹，但无论如何，这依然是一种壮观的自杀。于是正如书中所述，粟津没有发生战斗。这个故事，我的意思是，这是有据可查的。没有理由怀疑这确实发生过。我想它的轮廓是准确的。是的，因为这感觉像是诗歌的内容，不是吗？感觉像是随着时间推移被润色过的内容。当然。
I mean, I think clearly the implosion of Kiso's power base, that's, that's, that's, accurate. And I think the pathos of his kind of, you know, this lonely end by the, by the pine trees. I think the place of his death was commemorated. That's, it's kind of very famous. I mean, are all the details accurate, as you say, almost certainly not, because by this point, poets are celebrating samurai in quite a traditional way. And they love to amplify the glamour, but they also love to amplify the jeopardy. And so you get this incredibly cinematic account of Kiso's death, you know, the ice on the paddy fields, the mud, the way he dies, the pine trees. You get this incredible battle cry of triumph from the guy who's killed him, the insistence on yelling out his
我的意思是，我认为木曾权力基础的崩溃显然是准确的。我认为他在松树旁那种孤独结局的悲怆感也是真实的。他死亡的地点被纪念了。这非常出名。我的意思是，所有的细节都准确吗？正如你所说，几乎肯定不是，因为到这个时候，诗人们正以一种相当传统的方式赞美武士。他们喜欢放大魅力，但也喜欢放大危险。所以你得到了这个令人难以置信的电影般的木曾之死，你知道，稻田上的冰，泥土，他死亡的方式，松树。你得到了那个杀了他的人令人难以置信的胜利战吼，那种坚持大声喊出他
name. You get Emma's melodramatic suicide. Maybe this happened or maybe it should have happened. but either way, it means that this episode again is one of those kind of paradigmatic moments that will reverberate through the centuries. Every samurai knows this story. And I think that this reflects the way in which the samurai themselves, as we said it, right in the first episode, you know, they are always actively and deliberately encouraging myth-making. And the rise and fall of someone like Lord Kiso, you know, it did dramatize.
名字的行为。你得到了今井那充满戏剧性的自杀。也许这发生了，或者也许它本该发生。但无论如何，这意味着这一集再次成为那些将在几个世纪中产生回响的范式时刻之一。每个武士都知道这个故事。我认为这反映了武士们自己，正如我们在第一集中所说的那样，他们总是积极且刻意地鼓励神话的创造。而像木曾大人这样的兴衰，确实戏剧化了。
for them, how precarious life was. You know, the famous lines with which the tale of the Heike opening, we had that at the beginning of episode two, the bold and brave perish in the end. They are as dust before the wind. This is the great Buddhist teaching. All things must pass. And also, the calling out of names on the battlefields. Maybe it didn't happen during the course of fighting, as it did in this account.
对他们来说，生命是多么脆弱。你知道，《平家物语》开篇那句名言，我们在第二集开头提到过，豪杰勇士终将灭亡。他们如风前的尘埃。这是伟大的佛教教义。万物皆有终结。还有，在战场上呼喊名字。也许在战斗过程中并没有像这个描述中那样发生。
But afterwards, I think that's absolutely plausible. I mean, it, you know, the delight the Desheda feels at killing. someone as famous as Kiso is entirely understandable because right the way through Samari history, the more glorious, the better born, the nobler, the more famous, the person you kill, the greater the glory that it brings to you. And it's very clear in all the accounts that kind of rank and file warriors, samurai with no great lineage or reputation, if they kill someone who's famous, you know, it immediately elevates them. It immediately amplifies their face. And, you know, again, the kind of the death of Ime, this horrible kind of detail of him putting the sword in the back of his throat and then kind of driving himself forward.
但事后，我认为这绝对是可信的。我的意思是，石田在杀死像木曾这样出名的人时感到的喜悦是完全可以理解的，因为在整个武士历史中，你杀的人越光荣、出身越好、越高贵、越出名，带给你的荣耀就越大。在所有的记载中都很清楚，那些普通士兵，没有显赫家世或名声的武士，如果他们杀了一个名人，你知道，这会立即提升他们的地位。它会立即放大他们的脸面。而且，你知道，再次提到今井的死，那种他把剑放进喉咙后部然后向前冲刺的可怕细节。
Did it happen? It should have done if it didn't because a dramatic suicide is a good suicide and a good suicide is a memorable suicide. And just a quick question, how do you think this compares with the kind of knightly culture of Europe in the Middle Ages? I think quite similar. But more exaggerated version in some ways, an even greater interest in lineage. and in fame or just the equivalent. I mean, they're not, they don't exactly map on to one another. But I think there are kind of aspects of knightly culture, as there are in samurai culture,
它发生了吗？如果没发生，它也应该发生，因为一场戏剧性的自杀是一场好的自杀，而一场好的自杀是一场令人难忘的自杀。顺便问一下，你认为这与欧洲中世纪的骑士文化相比如何？我认为相当相似。但在某些方面是更夸张的版本，对血统有更大的兴趣。以及对名声或等同物。我的意思是，它们并不完全对应。但我认为骑士文化中存在某些方面，正如武士文化中存在的那样，
that are celebrated by poets and which then influence the way that knights behave, and that behaviour then in turn influences poets. So it's a kind of, you know, it's the knightly culture and the poetic culture are kind of fueling one another. And it's that which brings us to Lady Tom away, who is a properly mysterious. figure who she just suddenly appears and then just suddenly vanishes. You know, she chops off the head of this guy and she's gone and we never hear about her again. It's not surprising that this this starring role, so unexpected, so unusual, so, so kind of fleeting, it absolutely encourages subsequent attempts to fill in the gaps. So in the wake of the tale of the Hakey, people are fascinated by her. They do want to know more. They want to know, you know, who had she been to Kiso? Had she been his servant? his concubine, his wife, how seasoned was she in combat?
受到诗人的赞美，这些赞美进而影响了骑士的行为，而这种行为反过来又影响了诗人。所以这是一种，你知道，骑士文化和诗歌文化在相互推动。正是这一点把我们带到了巴夫人这里，她是一个真正神秘的人物，她突然出现，然后又突然消失。你知道，她砍下了这个人的头，然后就走了，我们再也没有听到过关于她的消息。难怪这个明星角色，如此出人意料，如此不同寻常，如此转瞬即逝，它绝对鼓励了后续填补空白的尝试。所以在《平家物语》之后，人们对她着迷。他们确实想知道更多。他们想知道，你知道，她对木曾来说是谁？她是他的仆人吗？他的妾，他的妻子，她在战斗中有多老练？
And so a tradition develops that she had actually commanded the division of Kiso's army at the Kura Kara Pass that had been stationed in Hell Valley. So all those Tyra soldiers who had jumped off the precipice and fallen into the valley and been cut up by the Minamoto soldiers stationed there, that she had been in command of them. But there's no evidence at the time that she was. I mean, this is an elaboration after the event, no? I mean, I suppose it's not completely impossible, because if it was completely impossible,
于是产生了一个传统，说她实际上在俱利伽罗峠指挥了木曾军队中驻扎在“地狱谷”的那一部分。所以所有那些跳下悬崖、掉进山谷并被驻扎在那里的源氏士兵砍杀的平氏士兵，都是由她指挥的。但当时没有证据表明她是。我的意思是，这是事后的润色，不是吗？我的意思是，我想这并非完全不可能，因为如果完全不可能，
people wouldn't have said that it had been possible, but I think it's probably unlikely. And then, of course, there's this great mystery about what did happen to her after she galloped off into the sunset. And again, various stories are kind of told to try and fill that gap. So some say that she continued her career as a warrior,
人们就不会说它曾经是可能的，但我认为这可能不太可能。然后，当然，关于她在策马奔向夕阳后到底发生了什么，有一个巨大的谜团。同样，人们讲述了各种各样的故事来试图填补这个空白。所以有人说她继续了她的武士生涯，
that she had a kind of glorious record. Other say that she was captured by one of Yoritomo's right-hand men, and made into effectively a sex slave, and others that she ended up as a nun. And so the range of stories that are told about her fate have led some scholars very disappointingly to suggest that she was completely fictional. But I'm happy to say, having on the basis of my fairly cursory research into this, that the consensus does seem a lot more positive than that,
她有一种光荣的记录。另一些人说她被赖朝的得力助手之一俘虏，实际上变成了性奴，还有人说她最终成了尼姑。所以关于她命运的故事范围之广，导致一些学者非常令人失望地认为她是完全虚构的。但我很高兴地说，基于我对此进行的相当粗略的研究，共识似乎比那要积极得多，
that most scholars of this period think that she was a real person who was kind of amplified into legend. Well, can we talk a bit about women more broadly? So women, girls from samurai families are taught how to ride a horse, sit in the saddle, use a bow and so on. And there are female warriors, aren't there? Onomusha, they're called. Yeah, they're completely recognised figures in Japanese culture.
大多数研究这一时期的学者认为她是一个真实的人，被放大成了传说。好吧，我们能谈谈更广泛的女性吗？所以女性，来自武士家庭的女孩被教导如何骑马、坐在马鞍上、使用弓箭等等。有女性武士，不是吗？她们被称为“女武者”。是的，她们是日本文化中完全公认的人物。
And most of them probably didn't carry swords as Tomoe did. But they were habituated to the use of the Naginata, which is that kind of halberd-like thing that was used. in the battle on the Uji bridge, the guy kind of batting away the arrows of his enemy. But this was often described in Japanese literature as the kind of the weapon per excellence that was used by female warriors, I guess because it was kind of maybe lighter than a sword. And there is an intriguing detail from archaeology, admittedly from centuries after Tomoe lived.
她们中的大多数人可能不像巴御前那样携带剑。但她们习惯于使用薙刀，也就是那种类似于戟的东西，在宇治川之战中，那个人用它挡开了敌人的箭。但这在日本文学中经常被描述为女性武士使用的卓越武器，我想可能是因为它比剑轻。而且有一个来自考古学的有趣细节，诚然是在巴御前生活几个世纪之后。
So there was in 2022, there was excavation of a site of a battle that had been fought in 1580. and that covered the remains of 105 individual warriors who had perished in this fight, and of those 105, 35 had been women. So I think the evidence for their having been female samurai is much stronger than, say, the evidence for having been female Vikings, which is, you know, people very much want to believe in. I think the evidence for female samurai is much stronger. So I think that, you know, the fact that Tommy undoubtedly does become a figure of myth,
所以，在2022年，人们挖掘了一个1580年发生的战场遗址，其中覆盖了在这场战斗中丧生的105名武士的遗骸，在这105人中，有35人是女性。所以我认为有女性武士的证据比，比如说，有女性维京人的证据要强得多，你知道，人们非常希望相信这一点。我认为女性武士的证据要强得多。所以我认为，你知道，巴御前无疑成为了一个神话人物的事实，
She becomes a star of kind of no theatre and kabuki and all this kind of thing. I mean, she's kind of very well-known figure right into the present in Japan. But it doesn't mean that she was always an exclusively a figure of myth. And it's a point really, really well made in the catalogue of the British Museum Samurai show by Rosina Buckland, the curator there. And she wrote, it, it is important to realize that myth-making was present from the very beginning and that it cannot be separated from historical fact, image-underpinned reality. because the samurai, as we've said, are always conscious of themselves as someone who is potentially going to be the star of a myth. And it's true of all the great figures in the samurai civil war.
她成为了能剧和歌舞伎等各种艺术形式的明星。我的意思是，她在日本一直是一个非常著名的人物，直到今天。但这并不意味着她一直仅仅是一个神话人物。大英博物馆武士展的策展人罗西娜·巴克兰在展览目录中非常出色地指出了这一点，她写道：“重要的是要意识到神话的创造从一开始就存在，它不能与历史事实分开，图像支撑着现实。”因为武士，正如我们所说，总是意识到自己是潜在的神话明星。这对于武士内战中的所有伟大人物来说都是如此。
So Kiomori, Kiso, Tom away. But actually, the guy of whom it is most true is the samurai who will come to rank simultaneously as the greatest general of the age, a figure who is clearly. you know, a man of history, a man who is shaping events, who is winning wars, who is altering the very course of Japanese history, but who also ends up as the kind of a cross between Robin Hood and King Arthur. And this is Minamoto No Yoshitsunei, and we met him in the previous episode. He is the younger half-brother of Yoritomo. He's the guy who'd won the Battle of Uji, and he was the guy who had captured Kyoto and more specifically
所以清盛、木曾、巴御前。但实际上，最符合这一点的人是那位将同时被列为那个时代最伟大将军的武士，一个显然是历史人物的人，一个正在塑造事件、赢得战争、改变日本历史进程的人，但他最终也成为了罗宾汉和亚瑟王的结合体。这就是源义经，我们在上一集中见过他。他是赖朝同父异母的弟弟。他就是赢得宇治川之战的人，也是夺取京都的人，更具体地说，
Gosherakawa, the cloistered emperor. That's right, but he's already in this series occupied a place in between history and legend, hasn't he? Because he also was sent off to a monastery and he was raised not knowing who his father was. Listeners may recall that he was taught swordsmanship by a sort of a demon or something
夺取了后白河法皇。没错，但他在这部系列剧中已经占据了一个介于历史和传说之间的位置，不是吗？因为他也被送到了寺院，他在不知道自己父亲是谁的情况下长大。听众可能还记得，他是由某种住在山下的恶魔或类似的东西教导剑术的。然后他与那个家伙战斗，那个像乔·马尔（橄榄球运动员）一样强壮的武士僧侣，在桥上，然后招募了他。记得吗，弁庆想打败1000个人还是什么的？一千个。一千个。
who lived underneath a mountain. And then he fought that bloke, the sort of warrior monk, who was built like Joe Marr. the rugby player on a bridge and then recruited him. Remember, Benkei wanted to defeat 100 people or something? A thousand. A thousand.
而只差一个就到1000了，因为这家伙是他的第1000个对手。然后弁庆就成了他的武士。所以他是一个非常好的例子，说明了这些角色是如何占据这个介于可验证的历史事实和诗歌、传说、民间故事等各种东西之间的奇怪的边缘世界。是的。所以下半场，他的职业生涯将走两条路线。
And only got a 999 because this bloke was his 1,000th. And then Benke became his samurai. So he is a really good example of how these characters occupy this strange kind of liminal world between verifiable historical fact and the stuff of kind of poetry and legend and folk tale and all of this kind of thing. Yeah. And so in the second half, His career will take two courses.
第一条路线，我们将看到他如何受到哥哥赖朝的委托，指挥源氏的战争努力，以及他如何率军出海对抗伟大的海军强权平氏。但我们也将看到，当他结束了武士内战后，他最终被逐出了哥哥的视线。他实际上退入了传说的维度。所以他将成为日本历史上的一个伟大人物，也将成为日本的罗宾汉。令人兴奋。所以休息后回来，我们将了解源义经是如何成为罗宾汉的。
So the first course, we will see how he is entrusted by his brother Yoritomo with the command of the Minamoto war effort and how he takes to the seas against the Taira, who are the great naval power. But we will also be seeing how, once he has brought the samurai civil war to a close, he ends up being banished from his brother's presence. And he withdraws effectively into the dimension of legend. So he is going to become a great figure in Japanese history and he is going to become the Robin Hood of Japan. Exciting. So come back after the break and we'll find out how Minamoto
欢迎回到《历史的余味》。所以我们一直在谈论义经，他是源氏族长赖朝的弟弟。他到目前为止表现非常出色。他伟大的竞争对手木曾已经被从武士的“权力的游戏”中淘汰了。现在义经要去日本西部对抗他们不共戴天的敌人——平氏。
nor Yotschitsune becomes Robin Hood. Welcome back to the rest is history. So we have been talking about Yoshitsune, who is the youngest brother of Yolitoomo, the head of the Minamoto clan. He's had a tremendous episode so far. He's, his great rival, Kiso, has been eliminated. from the Samurai Game of Thrones. And now Yoshitsune is off to fight their sworn enemies in the west of Japan, the Tyra.
现在的区别在于，平氏在海上和陆地上都非常强大。所以汤姆，他将如何应对这一点？这将很困难，因为源氏不是海军强权。他们并没有真正的船只。这意味着平氏将非常、非常难以被彻底击败，因为他们控制着内海。这些水域与本州西部及其南部的另外两个岛屿接壤。
Now, the difference here is the Tyra are very formidable on sea as well as on land. So Tom, how is he going to cope with that? It's going to be difficult because the Minamoto are not a naval power. They don't really have ships. And that means that the Tyra are going to be very, very difficult to bring to a decisive defeat, because they control the inland sea. And these are the waters which border western hanshu and immediately to its south these two other islands.
所以四国，它直接与本州西部平行，所以如果你把它想象成映射到英国，它就像一个巨大的怀特岛，沿着南海岸平行延伸。然后是九州，就像我们说的，如果它是一个粘在西南部的岛屿，它就像康沃尔和德文郡。而分隔九州和本州的狭窄海峡，
So Shikoko, which lies directly parallel to western hansu, so if you think of it as maybe mapping onto England, it's like an enormous Isle of White, kind of running parallel to the south coast. And then Kusu, which is like we said, it's like kind of Cornwall and Devon, if it was an island kind of stuck on the south-west. And the straits that separate,
窄到今天有一座桥跨越它。所以这本质上，你知道，这些是平氏逃往的航道、港口和岛屿。因为他们知道源氏没有海军能力，如果他们以这些岛屿为基地，他们实际上是无法触及的。所以他们在四国，在九州，还有在一个叫屋岛的地方，那是四国东北海岸外的一个火山岛，他们认为源氏没有船，如果我们待在这里，我们就安全了。话虽如此，他们在本州大陆的海岸上也有一个基地，距离京都大约三天的路程，这个地方叫一之谷，他们不想
Kushu and Honshu are so narrow that today they are spanned by a bridge. So this essentially, you know, these are the shipping lanes, the ports, the islands that the Tyra have fled to. And because they know that the Minamoto have no naval capacity, if they base themselves on these islands, they're effectively inaccessible. So they are in Shikoko, they are on Kushu, but also on a place called Yashima, which is a volcanic island immediately off the coast of northeastern
完全放弃本州。我的意思是，这就是为什么他们把基地设在一之谷，因为他们认为那里是坚不可摧的。它坐落在非常、非常陡峭的悬崖之下，每个人都认为这些悬崖是不可能下降的。而位于他们基地东西两侧的海滩则由非常高的墙壁守卫。所以他们觉得，你知道，在那里完全安全。
Shikoko and they assume Minamoto have no ships, we are safe if we stay here. Now having said that, they do also have a base on the coast of mainland Honshu about three days ride from Kyoto and this is a place called Ichinotani and they don't want to
汤姆，我有一种感觉，你不会告诉我关于高耸的悬崖和坚不可摧的局势，除非，事实上，这个地方并非坚不可摧，而且有人即将攻占它。我的意思是，这就是本质。每当有人在历史播客中描述一个坚不可摧的堡垒时，你就知道它会在两页笔记后陷落。特别是如果你现场有像义经这样的绝对传奇人物，因为被告知悬崖无法下降正是他喜欢的那种挑战。所以，你知道，他被告知，噢，没有任何骑兵能骑马下这些悬崖。他问告诉他这个消息的当地人，你知道，好吧，鹿能下这个悬崖吗？
abandon Honshu completely. I mean that's why and they have based themselves in Ichinotani because they think it is impregnable. It's kind of nestled between beneath very, very steep cliffs, which everyone assumes are impossible to descend. And the beaches that lie to the eastern west of their base are guarded by very high walls. So they feel, you know, completely secure there.
他被告知，是的，鹿可以穿过。为什么呢，义经惊呼道，这听起来像是一个真正的骑马场。如果鹿能穿过，马也能。于是他把两匹无人的马赶下悬崖，看着它们下去，它们成功地找到了路。
Tom, I have the sense that you wouldn't tell me that about the high cliffs and the impregnable situation, unless, in fact, this place was not impregnable, and somebody was about to take it. I mean, that's the nature. Whenever someone describes an impregnable citazel on a history podcast, you know that it's going to fall about two pages. of notes later. Particularly if you've got an absolute legend like Yoshitsune on the scene, because being told that a cliff can't be descended is exactly the kind of challenge that he loves. And so, you know, he's informed, oh, there's no way that any horseman can ride down these cliffs. And he asks the local who's told him this, you know, well, can deer get down this cliff face?
一旦这两匹马到达底部，义经转身对武士们说：“我们走吧。”于是他们下去了。这非常像《指环王：双塔奇兵》的结尾，甘道夫带领洛汗骑兵冲下一座不可思议的陡峭山坡。
And he's told, yeah, the deer, they can get through. Why then, Yoshitsune exclaimed, it sounds like a veritable riding ground. If deer can get through Soken horses. And so he sends two riderless horses down the side of the cliff and he watches them go down and they manage to make their way.
是的，是的。这是一个精彩的场景。而且，当然，这非常像巴御前，因为我们在你读的那段文字中被告知，她能骑着最狂野的马从最陡峭的斜坡上冲下。所以这显然是一种武士技能和虚张声势的衡量标准。所以《平家物语》说，他下去了，那是义经，每个人都跟着，压抑着对马的欢呼和喊叫。落差太陡了，他们闭上了眼睛。这些壮举看起来几乎是超人的。这是神或恶魔的事，而不是凡人的事。我的意思是平氏，一旦他们躲进了一个被告知是坚不可摧的据点，他们就应该知道这会发生。
And once these two horses have got to the bottom, Yoshitsunei turns around to the samurai. He says, let's go. And down they go. And it's very like the end of two towers, the Peter Jackson film, where Gandalf leads the riders of Rowan down an improbably steep hill.
他们应该读过日本历史故事之类的。但也许他们没有意识到他们身处史诗诗篇中。那曾经是状态。不，也许他们没有。无论如何，他们被这突如其来的袭击打了个措手不及，不是吗？他们中的大量人员立即被砍倒。一之谷被付之一炬。如果平氏没有准备好船只随时准备出发，整场战争可能就在那时此地解决了。
Yeah, yeah. It's a brilliant scene. And also, of course, it's very Tomaway, because we're told in that passage that you read, and she could ride the wildest horse down the steepest slope. So it's obviously a kind of measure of samurai skill and bravado. And so the tale of the Heke says, down he went, that's your Shitsune, everyone followed stifling whoops and shouts to the horses. The drop was so steep, they shut their eyes. The feet seemed all but superhuman. Something for gods or demons, not men. I mean the Tyra, as soon as they took refuge in a stronghold that they were told was impregnable, they should have known this was coming.
就像特洛伊平原上的希腊人一样。海滩上发生了一场大战，但大多数平氏人能够逃上船并航行离开。在那些设法登上船的人中，有五岁的天皇安德天皇，和他在一起的，至关重要的是，这套加冕或确立新天皇所必须的皇室神器。只要安德天皇带着它，源氏就无法将新天皇推上皇位。
They should have read the tales of Japanese history and whatnot. But maybe they didn't realize they were in an epic poem. That was ever state. No, maybe they didn't. Anyway, they're taken by surprise by this, aren't they? And huge numbers of them are cut down immediately. Itchinatani is put to the torch. And the whole war would probably have been settled there and then had the Tyra not had their ship lined up ready to go.
所以这对平氏来说算是一个结果。我们能重点谈谈这场战斗中的一个特定片段吗，因为这场战斗显然在日本诗歌和传说中非常受赞誉。而《平家物语》谈到了一些，很像《伊利亚特》之类的，它聚焦于个人，那些在这场战斗中表现出惊人壮举的英雄。
So like the Greeks on the plains of Troy. And there's a great battle on the beach, but most of the Tyra are. able to escape onto their boats and sail away. And among those who managed to get onto a boat is the five-year-old emperor Antokou, and with him, crucially, this imperial regalia that you have to have, if you're going to crown or institute a new emperor. And as long as Antoku keeps that with him, then the Minamoto can't put a new emperor on the throne.
这些壮举随后成为后世几十年和几个世纪武士的灵感来源。所以最著名的是这个叫熊谷直实的人。熊谷直实发生了什么？是什么让他如此出名？他是一个出身低微的武士，因此他渴望提升自己的地位和名声。
So that's kind of a result for the Taira. Can we just focus in on a particular episode from this battle because obviously this battle greatly celebrated in kind of Japanese poetry and legend and stuff. And the tale of the heke talks about some of the, rather like the Iliad or something, it focuses in on individuals, heroes who perform tremendous feats in this battle.
所以他做了这种经典的武士行为，想要成为第一个冲进战场的人。所以他没有加入义经那种骑马下悬崖的行动，而是通过带着他的儿子——一个叫直家的人，进行某种父子联谊，对保护海滩的侧翼墙壁之一进行了完全疯狂的正面突击。而且，你知道，这是这种经典的武士行为。他想成为第一个冲进战场的人。他确实翻过了墙。他的儿子受了重伤。熊谷对此非常难过。
And those feats then become an inspiration for generations of samurai in the decades and centuries afterwards. So the most famous one is this guy, Kumagai Naozan. And what happens to Kumagai in Nawazane? And what makes him so celebrated? He's a low-born samurai and therefore he's desperate to kind of boost his standing
这些壮举随后成为了此后数十年乃至数百年间武士们的灵感来源。最著名的一位是熊谷直实。熊谷直实身上发生了什么？又是什么让他如此出名？他出身低微，因此渴望提升自己的地位
and his reputation. And so he does this classic samurai thing of wanting to be the first into battle. And so rather than join Yoshitsune in this kind of, you know, descent on their horses down the cliff, he has gone in for some kind of father-son bonding by taking his son,
和声望。于是他做了武士的典型举动，想要成为第一个冲入战场的人。因此，他没有加入义经那种骑马冲下悬崖的行动，而是带着儿子去进行某种父子间的联谊，
a guy called Naoi, along for a completely lunatic full frontal assault on, you know, one of the flanking walls that is protecting the beach. And it's, you know, it's this kind of classic samurai thing. He wants to be the first into the battle. And he does get over the wall. His son is invalided out. Kumagai is very upset about this.
一个叫直家的家伙，进行了一场完全疯狂的正面突击，目标是保护海滩的侧翼城墙之一。这是一种典型的武士行为。他想成为第一个冲进战场的人。他确实翻过了城墙。他的儿子因伤退出了战斗。熊谷对此感到非常难过。
He's kind of brooding on it. And as the Tyra are making their escape, he joins the Minamoto and he rides down to the beach to carry on the fight. And he sees a Tyra warrior who is swimming out to one of the ship. and this warrior we're told wears delicately tinted green armour, a helmet with spreading horns, a sword with gold fittings, and on his back arrows fletched with mottled feathers. And Kumagai calls out to him and says, hey, stop running away, don't be a coward, come back and fight. And the Tyra warrior hears this, he stopped swimming and he turns round.
他似乎在沉思。当平氏一族逃跑时，他加入了源氏，骑马冲向海滩继续战斗。他看到一名平氏武士正游向其中一艘船。据我们所知，这名武士身穿精致的淡绿色盔甲，头戴长着犄角的头盔，佩戴着金饰的宝剑，背上插着箭羽斑驳的箭。熊谷直实对他大喊，嘿，别跑了，别做懦夫，回来战斗。平氏武士听到了，停止了游泳，转过身来。
And he, you know, wades back up through the shallows. And they start fighting. And Kumagai is much too strong, much too powerful, much too. experienced for this much slighter warrior, and Kumagai wrestles the Tyra down onto the ground, and he tears off his adversary's helmet. And we're told he beheld a youth in his 16th or 17th year, his face lightly powdered, his teeth blackened about the same age as his own son, and to powder your face and to blacken your teeth is a marker of aristocratic status in the imperial court.
他，你知道，从浅滩涉水回来。他们开始交战。熊谷比这个身材瘦小的武士强壮得多、有力得多、经验也丰富得多。熊谷将平氏武士摔倒在地，扯下了对手的头盔。据记载，他看到的是一个十六七岁的少年，脸上涂着淡淡的脂粉，牙齿染黑，和他自己的儿子年纪相仿。在宫廷中，涂脂粉和染黑牙齿是贵族身份的象征。
And this is a kind of very, very handsome, almost pretty youth. and Kumagai demands to know the name of this young man, and the young man refuses. I am a worthy opponent, he says. Take my head and ask around. But Kumagai stares down at him, and he's thinking of his own son, who is, you know, dangerously injured.
这是一个非常、非常英俊，甚至可以说是秀气的少年。熊谷要求知道这个年轻人的名字，但年轻人拒绝了。他说，我是一个值得尊敬的对手。拿走我的首级去打听吧。但熊谷盯着他，想到了自己那个受了重伤、命悬一线的儿子。
And he hesitates and he thinks, I should spare this boy. He has all his life ahead of him. You know, I challenged him to battle, and I shouldn't have done, because he wasn't ready to compete with me. But as he's thinking this, he sees a great crowd of samurai moving down towards them.
他犹豫了，心想，我应该饶了这个孩子。他的人生才刚刚开始。你知道，是我向他发起的挑战，我不该这么做，因为他还没准备好与我抗衡。但就在他思考时，他看到一大群武士正向他们涌来。
And the boy, he sees this as well. And he's afraid that he's going to be dishonoured before them if Kumagai doesn't take his head. And so he says to Kumagai, come on, get a move on, you know, decapitate me. Alas, Kumagai murmured in bitter grief, the warrior's calling is harder than any. Had I not been born to a warlike house, never would I have known such sorrow. And so he draws his sword and he beheads the youth. And then he finds that this young boy had a flute, which like blackened teeth and powdered skin, is kind of emblematic of aristocratic grace and sophistication and learning. And he has this flute in a bag at his waist.
那个少年也看到了。他担心如果熊谷不取他的首级，他在这些人面前会蒙受耻辱。于是他对熊谷说，来吧，快点，你知道，砍下我的头。熊谷悲痛地喃喃自语道，唉，武士的使命比任何职业都艰难。如果我不是出生在武士世家，我就不会经历这样的悲伤。于是他拔出剑，斩下了少年的头颅。随后他发现这个少年身上带着一支笛子，就像染黑的牙齿和涂粉的皮肤一样，这是贵族优雅、世故和学识的象征。他把这支笛子装在腰间的袋子里。
So it's clear that this young man is a man of tremendous breeding. And subsequently, Kumagai learns that he was a young man called Atso-Mori, the son of an exceedingly high-ranking Tyra Lord. and that this flute had been a personal gift to him from the cloistered emperor, Tober, who died way back in episode two. And Kumagai is so distraught at what he's done and at the way that he's brought death to this brilliant young man that he ends up becoming a monk. He chucks in the samurai business completely. And we're also told that when Kumagai, he's on the beach of Ichinatani,
所以很明显，这个年轻人出身极其高贵。后来，熊谷得知他叫敦盛，是一位地位极高的平氏领主的儿子。这支笛子是退位天皇鸟羽天皇送给他的私人礼物，而鸟羽天皇早在第二集就去世了。熊谷对自己所做的一切以及给这位才华横溢的年轻人带来死亡的方式感到无比痛苦，最终他出家做了和尚。他彻底放弃了武士生涯。我们还被告知，当熊谷在一之谷的海滩上时，
he's holding the head of this young man who he's decapitated, and he goes to present the head to Yoshitsune, the sight of it we are told drew tears from everyone. So all the samurai share in this feeling of grief. What are they grieving? The fact that he's aristocratic or the fact that he's young? I think both. I think they feel grief for the kind of the old aristocratic order
他手里拿着那个被他斩首的少年的头颅，去向源义经呈报。据记载，这一幕让所有人都流下了眼泪。所以所有的武士都感同身受。他们在哀悼什么？是因为他出身贵族，还是因为他年纪轻轻？我认为两者皆有。我认为他们是在为那种正在被武士阶层取代的旧贵族秩序感到悲伤。
that the samurai are starting to eclipse. But I think they are also starting to kind of fashion for them, a new culture which derives from the courtly culture, but is something novel and very rich, very vivid in emotion. And the reason that this episode reverberates so profoundly is that it's almost like a passing of the torch, a passing of the torch from the courtly culture to the samurai culture. And what you're seeing here are samurai who are starting to celebrate their own stories, their own notions of nobility, their own heroes. And of course, of all these heroes, the greatest was as he remains to this day, Yoshitsune himself. This is the moment where
但我认为他们也开始为自己塑造一种新的文化，这种文化源于宫廷文化，但又是一种新颖、丰富且情感极其生动的文化。这一集之所以产生如此深远的影响，是因为它就像是一场火炬的传递，从宫廷文化传递到武士文化。你在这里看到的是武士们开始赞美他们自己的故事、他们自己的贵族观念、他们自己的英雄。当然，在所有这些英雄中，最伟大的一位，直到今天依然是源义经本人。这就是我们看到
we see samurai culture starting to emerge in the form that still exists to this day that we're familiar with to this day. Right. Now, Yoshitsunei has always, you know, because he's a Minamoto, he's been fighting on land, he's been fighting his way across Honshu. But of course, the issue now is that the Tyra have fled by sea, haven't they? So he's going to have to become a naval hero as well as a land one if he's going to carry the fight to them. Yes. So he's essentially, he's a, you know, he's a Napoleon, very young and dashing, herring around all over the place, who transforms himself into a Nelson. And one year after this great victory at Echinatani, Yashitsine launches his first amphibious expedition.
武士文化开始以我们今天所熟悉的形式出现的那一刻。没错。现在，源义经一直以来，因为他是源氏，他一直在陆地上作战，一直在本州岛上奋战。但当然，现在的问题是平氏已经从海上逃走了，不是吗？所以如果他想继续追击他们，他就必须成为一名海军英雄，而不仅仅是陆军英雄。是的。所以他本质上，你知道，他是一个非常年轻、风度翩翩的拿破仑，到处奔波，然后把自己变成了一个纳尔逊。在一之谷大捷一年后，义经发起了他的第一次两栖远征。
And he does it by sea in the teeth of an absolute gale. to Shikoku, this island to the south of Honshu. And then having landed, unobserved by the Taira, he leads his cavalry overland by night, so as to maximise the surprise, to the Taira base on this volcanic island of Yashima, which we mentioned. And Yoshitsine and his men are able to attack this base because, as they had been informed by a local,
他是在狂风中从海上出发的，前往本州岛南部的四国岛。登陆后，在平氏未察觉的情况下，他连夜率领骑兵在陆地上行军，以最大限度地实现突袭，直奔我们提到的那个火山岛——屋岛上的平氏基地。义经和他的部下能够袭击这个基地，因为正如当地人告诉他们的那样，
at low tide, you can ride out the island and not even wet your horse's belly. So it's kind of very fordable. And the Tyra, again, the Minamoto pull this trick, which Kiso had also been keen on, of raising up kind of phantom banners to make it seem like there's a much larger force than there actually is. The Minamoto see these banners and they panic and they all pile into their ships again and the ships pull out to sea and they essentially abandon their base. And it's a victory for your Shitsunei. You know, he's captured their base.
在退潮时，你可以骑马穿过岛屿，甚至不会弄湿马肚子。所以那里非常容易涉水。平氏一族，源氏再次使用了木曾义仲也曾热衷的诡计，竖起各种虚假的旗帜，让人觉得他们的兵力比实际要多得多。平氏看到这些旗帜后惊慌失措，纷纷涌向他们的船只，船只驶向大海，他们基本上放弃了基地。这对义经来说是一场胜利。你知道，他占领了他们的基地。
He's forced them off Shikoku. But because the Tira have been able to withdraw, and because they, again, they take the emperor and Tuku with them and the imperial regalia, it's still indecisive. You know, they had the first battle, indecisive, the second battle, third time lucky? I mean, in a poem, it's always the third battle as the winner, isn't it? But the thing is, I mean, it is. But this is also historical fact. We know that this isn't just kind of completely made up.
他迫使他们离开了四国。但由于平氏能够撤退，而且因为他们再次带着安德天皇和三神器一起逃走，所以这仍然是不确定的。你知道，他们进行了第一次战斗，不分胜负，第二次战斗，事不过三？我的意思是，在诗歌中，总是第三次战斗才是赢家，不是吗？但问题是，我的意思是，确实如此。但这也是历史事实。我们知道这不仅仅是完全编造的。
But these battles are authenticated in sources from the time. So, and I think this is another reason why Yishitsine is such a potent figure, is that he leads his life as though he's already a hero in a kind of epic poem. And people clearly feel that at the time. So third time lucky, it's one month later, 25th of April, 1185. And Yashitine meets the entire Tira battle fleet in what is going to prove the climactic clash of the Samurai Civil War. And the setting now is the waters that border the very westernmost point of Honshu.
这些战斗在当时的文献中都有记载。所以，我认为这也是义经成为如此有影响力的人物的原因之一，他的一生就像是一首史诗中的英雄。当时的人们显然也有这种感觉。所以事不过三，一个月后，即1185年4月25日，义经在武士内战的决定性冲突中迎战了整个平氏舰队。现在的战场是本州岛最西端的边缘水域。
So these are the narrow straits today across by bridge that separate Honshu from the neighbouring island of Kushu. So at Yashima, so a month before, Yoshitsune had been a little bit hesitant about facing that IRISC, hadn't he? Because they're the experts on sea. he's a relative novice but now he's absolutely going to go for it and what has changed new ships new tactics what's the difference yeah i think it's a bit like the romans
所以这些就是今天有桥梁横跨的狭窄海峡，将本州岛与邻近的九州岛隔开。所以在屋岛，也就是一个月前，义经在面对平氏时还有点犹豫，不是吗？因为他们是海战专家，而他相对是个新手，但现在他绝对要全力以赴了。发生了什么变化？新船？新战术？有什么不同？是的，我觉得这有点像罗马人
attacking the carthaginians in the first punic war you know they're not proficient sailors but um eishitsunei is confident now that he has enough ships to um to at least rival the number that the the tyra have at the minimoto shipyards have been working flat out because of course um yeshitsunei has seized them from the tyra by conquering most of Western Honshu. It's evident, I think, by this point to most people that the Minamoto are going to win. And so there have been a lot of defections.
在第一次布匿战争中攻击迦太基人，你知道他们不是熟练的水手，但是，义经现在很有信心，他有足够的船只，至少可以与平氏的数量相抗衡。源氏的造船厂一直在全力运转，因为当然，义经通过征服本州岛西部大部分地区，从平氏手中夺取了这些船只。我认为到目前为止，对大多数人来说，源氏必胜已经很明显了。所以有很多倒戈投降的情况。
You know, ships and sailors have gone over to your Shitsune. And also by cornering the Taira in these very narrow straits, he senses a real opportunity. This is his chance finally to win a decisive battle. Because beyond these straits, there is nothing but open sea. you know, all the way to Korea. So the Tyra essentially have nowhere to go if they lose. They have to stand and fight.
你知道，船只和水手都投向了义经。而且，通过将平氏困在这些非常狭窄的海峡中，他感觉到了一个真正的机会。这是他最终赢得决定性战斗的机会。因为在这些海峡之外，除了公海，什么都没有。你知道，一直到韩国。所以平氏如果输了，基本上无处可去。他们必须站稳脚跟进行战斗。
And all of these are factors that lead your Shitsune to think this is the moment. But above all, of course, you know, we compared him to Nelson. He has those qualities. He has boldness. He has vision. He has drive. He has a kind of sense for the moment. And the battle begins kind of towards midday.
所有这些因素都让义经认为这就是时机。但最重要的是，当然，你知道，我们把他比作纳尔逊。他具备那些品质。他有胆识。他有远见。他有动力。他有一种对时机的把握。战斗在中午左右开始。
It's the late morning. And by the late afternoon, Yashitsune has effectively won. The Taira Fleet have been caught by this massive rip tide. And they're starting to drift helplessly backwards towards a rocky beach on the shore of Honshu called Danora. And this time, there's no escape for the little boy, Emperor Antakou. He's had a tough time, that boy. He's just spent his whole life kind of jumping onto ships and being ferret away. But this time, there is nowhere for him to go.
那是深夜。到了傍晚，义经实际上已经赢了。平氏舰队被这股巨大的激流困住了。他们开始无助地向后漂向本州岛岸边一个叫坛之浦的岩石海滩。这一次，小男孩安德天皇没有逃脱的机会。那个孩子过得很艰难。他一生中大部分时间都在跳上船只，被带走。但这一次，他无处可去。
And so he's with his grandmother, who is the widow of Kiamori, the great Tyra Lord, who died of horrible temperature. And Antiku's grandmother folds a little boy in her arms, and then she speaks probably the most famous last words in the entire history of the samurai, incredibly celebrated in Japan. And she tells the boy, down there beneath the waves, another capital. So another Kyoto awaits us. and then she jumps with him into the sea and they sink. Good line. It's a really good line.
所以他和他的祖母在一起，她是平氏伟大的领主平清盛的遗孀，清盛死于可怕的高烧。安德天皇的祖母把小男孩抱在怀里，然后她说出了可能是整个武士历史上最著名的遗言，在日本广为传颂。她告诉孩子，在那波涛之下，有另一个都城。另一个京都等待着我们。然后她抱着他跳入大海，他们沉了下去。好台词。这真是一句好台词。
I mean, I respect it, yeah. A really good line. And the ceremonial sword, you know, which you need to inaugurate a new emperor, that also, it is said, banishes into the depths, although opinions differ. There are those in Japan who say that it was recovered. But I think the consensus generally is that that goes forever. It's lost. It's still down there in the straits.
我的意思是，我尊重它，是的。真是一句好台词。而且那把用于新天皇即位的仪式宝剑，据说也消失在深渊中，尽管观点不一。日本有人说它被找回了。但我认为普遍的共识是它永远消失了。它丢了。它还在海峡下面。
Fortunately, the mirror and the jewel do survive and, you know, there's still in existence to this day. And there is a sword which some say, you know, I think probably fake, but don't come at me if you're Japanese. So they've gone and all across the Taira battle fleet, the samurai are thinking, this is it, we're all over. And they see the emperor and his grandmother jump into the waves. And so they start to follow. And most of them pick up anchors or they put on kind of extra layer of armor to ensure that they will sink. And never before in the history of the samurai had there been such a mass suicide. How many people? Thousands and thousands sinking down into the depths. There are
幸运的是，镜子和珠宝确实幸存了下来，而且，你知道，至今仍然存在。还有一把剑，有些人说，你知道，我想可能是假的，但如果你是日本人，别来找我麻烦。所以他们走了，整个平氏舰队的武士都在想，就是这样，我们完了。他们看到天皇和他的祖母跳进波浪中。于是他们开始跟随。他们中的大多数人捡起锚，或者穿上额外的盔甲以确保自己会沉下去。武士历史上从未有过如此大规模的自杀。多少人？成千上万的人沉入深渊。有
survivors. So Ken Raimonin, in, who is the mother of Antakou, the daughter of Kiamori, she weighed down her robes and she threw herself into the sea. But there was a Minamoto sailor saw her and reached Dan with a grappling hook, caught her by the hair, hauled her in. So she survived. And Munamori, who is her brother and the highest ranking of all the Tyra, so the eldest surviving son of Kiamori, he also was captured because he had hesitated to jump. So in a way, he's the kind of the Bruce Ismay of the samurai, the guy. Oh yeah. He's the coward. Is he lambasted for the rest of his life like Bruce Ismay was? Yes, he is, as we will see. Oh, no. And the survival of Munamori, it kind of only emphasizes the sheer annihilation of everyone else and the Tyra clan.
幸存者。所以建礼门院，也就是安德天皇的母亲，平清盛的女儿，她穿上沉重的长袍，投身大海。但有一名源氏水手看到了她，用抓钩够住她，抓住她的头发，把她拉了上来。所以她活了下来。而宗盛，也就是她的兄弟，平氏中地位最高的人，也就是清盛的长子，他也因为犹豫而没有跳海，所以被俘了。所以从某种意义上说，他是武士中的布鲁斯·伊斯梅（泰坦尼克号船长），那个家伙。哦，是的。他是懦夫。他像布鲁斯·伊斯梅一样被嘲笑了一辈子吗？是的，正如我们将要看到的。哦，不。而宗盛的幸存，在某种程度上更加突显了其他所有人和平氏一族的彻底覆灭。
Again, there are these incredibly famous lines from the tale of the Heki. Red flags and badges littered the sea like autumn leaves gripped by the wind and scattered on the Tatsuta River. Once white, the waves on the shore broke pink. Boats drifted, empty and abandoned, the will only of wind and tide, aimlessly rocking, a desolate scene. almost the strangest story told is that the spirits of the dead tyre are all the ones who had killed themselves by jumping into the sea migrated into the crabs that scuttle along the beach of danaura and can still be seen there to this day and dominet you're pulling a face no just just a face of a crab actually should you or anyone be skeptical then have a look at the shells of these crabs the haikagani they call the tina crabs and on these shelves of the tina crabs
同样，平家物语中有这些极其著名的台词。红色的旗帜和徽章散落在海上，就像被风吹落并散落在龙田川上的秋叶。曾经洁白的岸边波浪被染成了粉红色。船只漂浮着，空无一人，被遗弃，任由风和潮汐摆布，漫无目的地摇晃，一片凄凉的景象。最奇怪的故事是，死去的平氏武士的灵魂，所有那些通过跳海自杀的人，都迁移到了在坛之浦海滩上横行的螃蟹身上，至今仍能在那里看到。多米尼克，你在做鬼脸。不，只是螃蟹的表情。实际上，如果你或任何人持怀疑态度，那就看看这些螃蟹的壳，他们称之为平家蟹，也就是这些平家蟹的壳上，
And on these shells, you will clearly see the faces of drowned samurai. No, I totally believe this. I'm not skeptical at all. So you were comparing this to the naval battle, I don't know, between, like, Rome and Carthage. But I mean, Roman Carthage had nothing on this. The young emperor with his grandmother going down to their capital beneath the waves, the sword that's disappeared and never found, the samurai crabs. I mean, this is good stuff.
在这些壳上，你会清楚地看到溺水武士的面孔。不，我完全相信这一点。我一点也不怀疑。所以你把这比作海战，我不知道，比如罗马和迦太基之间。但我的意思是，罗马和迦太基根本比不上这个。小天皇和他的祖母沉入波涛之下的都城，消失且从未被发现的宝剑，武士螃蟹。我的意思是，这真是太棒了。
Yeah. It's an incredibly haunting, eerie battle as well as being, you know, completely decisive in this great war, this great samurai civil war. And I think that this is also a crucial aspect of what makes your Shitsune the most famous of all the samurai. Because the battle crowns what has been the greatest succession of victories in the history of the samurai. You know, these three great naval battles. And before that, he'd captured Kyoto and he'd force the bridge at Uji, all of these great victories. But also, yeshitsune himself is folded into the aura of tragedy because it is for him a pinnacle of greatness. And from this moment on, the only way is down.
是的。这是一场令人难以忘怀、毛骨悚然的战斗，同时也是这场伟大的战争，这场伟大的武士内战中决定性的战斗。我认为这也是使义经成为所有武士中最著名人物的关键因素。因为这场战斗为他赢得了武士历史上最伟大的胜利。你知道，这三场伟大的海战。在此之前，他占领了京都，强行突破了宇治桥，所有这些伟大的胜利。但同时，义经本人也被笼罩在悲剧的氛围中，因为对他来说，这是伟大的巅峰。从这一刻起，他只能走下坡路。
The future is not good for this great victor in the war. So I'm wondering if part of this is to do with the dynamic that is always slightly fateful in history, which is he's the younger brother and his elder brother is the person really for whom he's fighting. And is his elder brother properly grateful and gracious in victory? He is so not. He's so ungrateful because Yoritomo, I think, is not a man who is in any way swayed by emotional sentiment. And he recognizes that Yashitsune now is the only person who could conceivably rival him as the master of Japan. Yeritzine has this reputation. He has the loyalty of all these men. Yorotomo hasn't fought a battle in this war. And so Yorotomo can recognize that if he is going to be completely secure, he has to get rid of his younger brother. And this perspective is solidified for him by the fact that in Kyoto, the Waili Go Shirikawa is already trying to foster divisions between them by kind of absolutely lavishing Yichitsunei with honors, which is almost calculated to infuriate Yoritomo. And Yoritomo is, you know, he is not in a mood to show clemency to anyone, and particularly not to the Tira either.
对于这位战争中的伟大胜利者来说，未来并不美好。所以我怀疑这是否与历史上总是带有宿命色彩的动态有关，那就是他是弟弟，而他的哥哥才是他真正为之战斗的人。他的哥哥在胜利后是否表现得足够感激和宽宏大量？他一点也不。他非常忘恩负义，因为我认为赖朝不是一个会被情感所左右的人。他意识到义经现在是唯一可能在地位上与他抗衡、成为日本主人的人。义经有这样的声望。他拥有所有这些人的忠诚。赖朝在这场战争中没有打过一场仗。所以赖朝可以意识到，如果他想完全稳固自己的地位，他就必须除掉他的弟弟。这种观点因为京都的后白河法皇已经在试图通过用荣誉来极度笼络义经，从而在他们之间制造分裂而变得更加坚定，这几乎是故意激怒赖朝。而赖朝，你知道，他并没有心情对任何人表现出宽容，尤其是对平氏。
So, Munamori, you know, the Bruce Ismay of the Taira, he is executed and his head is exhibited in Kyoto Marketplace. I mean, if you're a fan of severed heads, Kyoto Marketplace has definitely been the place to be for the past few years. All his children are either drowned or buried alive. And poor Ken Raimonin, so the mother of the drowned emperor, the boy emperor, she is spared but she's sent to a particularly poverty-stricken nunnery where she lives the rest of her life. So that's the Tyragon. But how is Yorotomo going to deal with Yoshitsunei?
所以，宗盛，你知道，平氏的布鲁斯·伊斯梅，他被处决了，他的头颅在京都市场展示。我的意思是，如果你是断头爱好者，过去几年京都市场绝对是必去之地。他所有的孩子要么被淹死，要么被活埋。可怜的建礼门院，也就是溺水天皇、小天皇的母亲，她幸免于难，但被送往一个特别贫困的尼姑庵，在那里度过了余生。这就是平氏的结局。但赖朝将如何处理义经呢？
Well, first of all, he refuses to see the victorious general. Yorotomo, you know, he's not having him anywhere near Kamakura. Then he strips him of all his lands. And then he attempts to have him assassinated. And although the assassination attempt fails, it's very, very clear to Yerushita. Shitsune, who it was had sponsored it. And so by the end of November, and this is the same year that he'd won, you know, his great victory over the Tyra at Dananura, Yoshitsune gets the message and he slips away from Kyoto and he vanishes effectively into the dimensions of legend.
嗯，首先，他拒绝接见这位胜利的将军。赖朝，你知道，他根本不让他靠近镰仓。然后他剥夺了他所有的领地。然后他试图暗杀他。虽然暗杀失败了，但义经非常清楚是谁指使的。所以到十一月底，也就是他赢得对平氏在坛之浦大捷的同一年，义经收到了消息，他从京都溜走，实际上消失在传说的维度中。
Because from this point on, he is basically Robin Hood. He is an outlaw. He's always escaping villainous lawmen who are trying to hunt him down. and of course he has a Little John in the form of this colossal warrior monk Benke. He is basically Friottuck and Little John combined into one character. Yes. And he ends up, so Robin Hood lurking around in the north of England and he is lurking around in the north of Japan. He is.
因为从这一点开始，他基本上就是罗宾汉。他是一个亡命之徒。他总是在逃避试图追捕他的邪恶执法者。当然，他有一个以这位高大的武僧弁庆为形式的“小约翰”。他基本上是弗莱尔·塔克和小约翰合二为一的角色。是的。他最终，就像罗宾汉潜伏在英格兰北部一样，他潜伏在日本北部。他确实是。
And as with Robin Hood, there are all these stories that are told about him. Again, incredibly famous in Japan, almost none of which I think are true. But what is true is the fact that by 1189, your Shitsunay, is cornered in the very far north of Honshu, so basically as far north as it's possible to go. And he's tracked down by a vast force of local samurai to an abandoned fort which stands behind a lonely river and there's clearly no escape from it. And so Yashitschitsenae himself retires into the fort where he commits Sepulco, he slits open his stomach.
正如罗宾汉一样，关于他有各种各样的故事。同样，在日本极其出名，我认为几乎没有一个是真的。但真实的是，到1189年，义经在本州岛的最北端被困住了，基本上是尽可能往北走。他被一支庞大的当地武士部队追踪到一个废弃的堡垒，堡垒后面是一条孤独的河流，显然没有逃脱的可能。所以义经本人退入堡垒，在那里他切腹自尽，他剖开了自己的肚子。
And outside while he's dying in this way, his tiny band of retainers are trying to hold off this kind of vast army that has gathered at its gates, but they inevitably are picked off one by one, and finally the story goes, only Benkei, this colossal warrior monk, his left. And he pauses the besieging force of samurai, so intimidated by him that they withdraw. Benkei leans on his great naginata, his halberd, and none of the enemy samurai dare to approach him. He's such a figure of kind of brooding and terrifying menace.
在他以这种方式死去时，他在外面，他那极少数的随从正试图抵挡聚集在门口的庞大军队，但他们不可避免地被一个接一个地干掉，最后故事说，只剩下弁庆，这个高大的武僧。他震慑了围攻的武士部队，他们被他吓得退缩了。弁庆倚靠着他巨大的薙刀，也就是长柄大刀，没有一个敌方武士敢靠近他。他是一个充满沉思和恐怖威胁的人物。
all is still for several minutes. And then a gust of wind blows and very, very slowly Benke keels over. And the samurai come forward to inspect him. And they realize that he's been dead for a while and only held up by all the arrows that have struck him through and are feathering him. That's a good story. It's very Wild West, isn't it? It's exactly the kind of story thing that you could imagine, you know, a shootout in a saloon
一切静止了几分钟。然后一阵风吹过，弁庆非常、非常缓慢地倒下了。武士们走上前去检查他。他们意识到他已经死了有一会儿了，只是被射中他身体的箭支撑着。那是个好故事。这非常像美国西部片，不是吗？这正是你所能想象的那种故事，你知道，沙龙里的枪战
or someone. He's been shot and then very slowly he topples over. and, you know, a tumbleweed goes past his dead body or whatever. However, I have a terrible feeling you're going to debunk this story and say they didn't happen. I like to think it happened. And we know for sure that Yoshitsina, I mean, he is cornered, he is killed and he is decapitated. And his head is sent from this fort in the far north of Honshu to his loving, his loving elder brother in Kamakura, Yoritomo. And it's preserved in sweet sake, we're told.
或者某人。他被击中了，然后非常缓慢地倒下，你知道，一团风滚草滚过他的尸体之类的。然而，我有一种可怕的感觉，你会揭穿这个故事，说它没有发生。我喜欢认为它发生了。我们确实知道义经，我的意思是，他被困住了，他被杀了，他被斩首了。他的头颅从本州岛最北端的这个堡垒被送到他在镰仓的、他那充满爱意的哥哥赖朝那里。据记载，它被保存在甜酒里。
Okay. And Yorotomo inspects it and disposes of it, and that seems to be the end of Yoshitsune. But as with Robin Hood, you know, there are stories that he survived and lived to old age. Similar stories are told of Yashitsune. And one of the most extraordinary stories, which develops much later, is that he had escaped to China and then made his way to Mongolia, where he became Genghis Khan. Wow. I mean, there are accounts of Genghis Khan as a boy and as a young man, no, so that would seem to conflict with them. But who knows? Strange things have happened. Well, have they? I mean, they probably haven't, but probably not. You know, these stories don't have to be true to be influential. And the stories that are told of your Shitsinae, in particular, over the course of the centuries, you know, they have a massive influence on the figure of the samurai as myth.
好的。赖朝检查并处理了它，这似乎就是义经的结局。但正如罗宾汉一样，你知道，有故事说他幸存下来并活到了高龄。关于义经也有类似的故事。最非凡的故事之一，是在很久以后发展起来的，说他逃到了中国，然后去了蒙古，在那里他成为了成吉思汗。哇。我的意思是，有关于成吉思汗作为男孩和年轻人的记载，不，所以这似乎与他们相冲突。但谁知道呢？奇怪的事情发生了。嗯，真的发生了吗？我的意思是，他们可能没有，但可能没有。你知道，这些故事不一定是真的才能产生影响。关于义经的故事，特别是几个世纪以来的故事，你知道，它们对作为神话的武士形象产生了巨大的影响。
and by extension, I think, therefore, on the figure of the cowboy in Westerns and on Luke Skywalker in Star Wars. I mean, we've said that. And so I think you could imagine that if your Shitsune were to meet Luke Skywalker, let's say that happens. There's a great joke coming up, everybody. Don't miss this great joke from Tom. Tom is going to make a Star Wars joke and this is very exciting. Go ahead, go ahead. What would your Shitsune say if he met Luke?
推而广之，我认为，因此，对西部片中的牛仔形象和《星球大战》中的卢克·天行者形象也产生了影响。我的意思是，我们说过这一点。所以我认为你可以想象，如果义经遇到卢克·天行者，假设发生了这种情况。大家注意，一个伟大的笑话要来了。不要错过汤姆这个伟大的笑话。汤姆要讲一个《星球大战》的笑话，这非常令人兴奋。来吧，来吧。如果义经遇到卢克，他会说什么？
He would say, I am your great, great, great, great, great, great. great, great, great, grandfather, Luke. Oh, what a great joke that is. Keep back of the net. George Luke is on the phone to you straight away. Why doesn't he feature that in one of his films? What a brilliant bit of sci-fi banter. Thank you.
他会说，我是你的高祖父，卢克。哦，多么伟大的笑话。球进了网。乔治·卢卡斯马上就给你打电话。为什么他不把这个放在他的电影里？多么精彩的科幻玩笑。谢谢。
Thank you very much. And also I hope you know that I've been saying video game throughout this series as well. That stunned me. That absolutely stunned me at the beginning of episode one. I was looking forward to laughing at you about the phrase computer game. And to my horror, you'd put video game. you had acknowledged that history had happened after the 1990 or something, and that astounded me. We've been doing this podcast for years and years now, and I like to think that I have learned from you.
非常感谢。而且我也希望你知道，我在整个系列中一直都在说“电子游戏”。这让我震惊。这在第一集开头就让我完全震惊了。我本来期待着嘲笑你使用“电脑游戏”这个词。令我惊恐的是，你用了“电子游戏”。你承认了历史发生在1990年之后什么的，这让我大吃一惊。我们做这个播客已经好几年了，我喜欢认为我从你那里学到了东西。
Yeah. A bit like your Shitsunei at the feet of the great demon in the mountain. Here's my real question. How did you know about the game Ghost of Tsushima? Is that in the British Museum exhibition or something? Because I knew that Samurai were a massive theme of video games. There's lots about that in the British Museum catalogue. I've got to be honest, of all the things we've done, we've done like 700 episodes.
是的。有点像在山中大魔王脚下的义经。这是我真正的问题。你是怎么知道《对马岛之魂》这款游戏的？那是大英博物馆的展览还是什么？因为我知道武士是电子游戏的一个巨大主题。大英博物馆的目录里有很多关于这方面的内容。老实说，在我们做过的所有事情中，我们做了大约700集。
regular episodes. We've of course done episodes for our Westis History Club members, and you can hear those episodes by signing up at the Restis History.com. But in all those hundreds and hundreds of episodes, nothing has blown my mind more than you starting with Ghost of Sushina. Thank you. I mean, that amazed me. My mission is done. Yeah. I mean, this is part of what makes a samurai so fascinating, is that they are part of the fabric of video games, right? I mean, in Japan, they're colossal, but they're also part of kind of Western video games. And that's what makes them so fascinating and
常规剧集。我们当然为我们的历史俱乐部成员制作了剧集，你可以通过在Restis History.com注册来收听这些剧集。但在那成百上千集中，没有什么比你以《对马岛之魂》开头更让我震惊的了。谢谢。我的意思是，这让我很惊讶。我的任务完成了。是的。我的意思是，这就是武士如此迷人的部分原因，因为他们是电子游戏结构的一部分，对吧？我的意思是，在日本，他们是巨大的，但他们也是西方电子游戏的一部分。这就是让他们如此迷人且
exceptional. Okay, let's get back to the history of the samurai, because the age of the samurai has now well and truly dawned. I mean, they are the masters of Japan now. Right, because they're not just figures of fantasy. They are, you know, they are now going to be the rulers of Japan, basically for 700 years. Yeah, of course.
非凡的原因。好的，让我们回到武士的历史，因为武士时代现在已经真正到来了。我的意思是，他们现在是日本的主人。没错，因为他们不仅仅是幻想中的人物。他们，你知道，他们现在基本上要统治日本700年了。是的，当然。
So, Yorotomo is the master of Japan right now. I mean, you describe him in your notes as restless, ruthless, and deeply unappealing. I mean, is he that unappealing? He's just one. I mean, I don't find that unappealing. I like to think that I wouldn't, for instance, hound my own brother to his death. I feel that that's very poor. And I'd like to think that you wouldn't either. I think that it's very unfraternal. I don't think he's an attractive figure, but he's a deeply, deeply impressive figure. And he is now effectively
所以，赖朝现在是日本的主人。我的意思是，你在笔记中形容他焦躁不安、冷酷无情且极其令人反感。我的意思是，他真的那么令人反感吗？他只是赢了。我的意思是，我不觉得那令人反感。我喜欢认为我不会，例如，追捕我自己的兄弟致死。我觉得那非常糟糕。我希望你也不会。我认为这非常不手足。我不认为他是一个有吸引力的人物，但他是一个非常、非常令人印象深刻的人物。而且他现在实际上是
the Master of Japan. And if you want to become Master of Japan, then he's obviously a tremendous role model. Yeah. There's absolutely that. And he makes clear his status as the new Master of Japan on the of November 1190, so that's five years after his younger brother had won this great battle at Dananura. And he travels to Kyoto, and this is his first visit to the capital as an adult. And his stay there is very brief. And the fact that he doesn't stay in Kyoto reflects the fact that, in the opinion of Yoritomo, Kamakura, this town, very close to what is now Tokyo, is effectively the new capital. of Japan, not officially, but effectively. And he doesn't want to be away from it for very long. Nevertheless, Kyoto is still, you know, it's the ancestral capital, it's the place where the emperor lives.
日本的主人。如果你想成为日本的主人，那么他显然是一个了不起的榜样。是的。绝对是这样。他在1190年11月明确了他的日本新主人的地位，也就是他弟弟在坛之浦赢得那场伟大战斗的五年后。他前往京都，这是他成年后第一次访问都城。他在那里的停留非常短暂。他没有留在京都的事实反映了赖朝的观点，镰仓，这个非常接近现在东京的城镇，实际上是日本的新都城，不是官方的，但实际上是。而且他不想离开那里太久。尽管如此，京都仍然是，你知道，它是祖先的都城，它是天皇居住的地方。
So it does matter. And so this is why he has gone there. His respect for the monarchy is authentic. You know, he's not a Cromwell to that extent. He's not going to abolish it. He's not going to replace it. That would be a bridge too far. But having said that, even though he respects the institution that the emperor
所以这确实很重要。这就是他去那里的原因。他对君主制的尊重是真实的。你知道，他不是那种程度上的克伦威尔。他不会废除它。他不会取代它。那将是过分之举。但话虽如此，尽管他尊重天皇所体现的机构，
embodies, he doesn't respect the most significant player in the imperial family. And this remains very crafty, the very inconstant, the very shifty Gosherakawa. And actually, Yorotomo sees Gosherakawa. He calls him a Tengu, a demon, someone who is not quite human. And so he's going there basically to put Gosherakawa in his box as well. You know, Kyoto, the whole of Japan, It needs the smack of firm government. And that being so, there can be no place for kind of scheming elderly, cloistered emperors, messing things up. You know, there can be no place for corrupt imperial favorites, cloistered emperors, any of these kind of people, they're all gone. They're not going to put up with them.
他不尊重皇室中最重要的人物。这仍然是非常狡猾、非常反复无常、非常阴险的后白河法皇。实际上，赖朝看到了后白河。他称他为“天狗”，一个恶魔，一个不完全是人类的人。所以他去那里基本上也是为了把后白河关进他的笼子里。你知道，京都，整个日本，它需要强有力的政府。既然如此，就没有那种阴险的老年、退位天皇搞乱事情的地方。你知道，没有腐败的皇室宠臣、退位天皇的地方，任何这类人，他们都完了。他们不会容忍他们。
The only class of person who can be trusted to provide good governance is Yorotomi's own class, the samurai class. And so this is where the notion of the samurai as the ruling elite is. in Japan is starting to bed down very firmly. And Yoratomo effectively delivers this message in Kyoto, and then he heads back to Kamakura, and he leaves the ancient capital behind. And it's a kind of a tremendous insult to Kyoto, but, you know, everyone there has to suck it up.
唯一可以信任提供良好治理的阶层是赖朝自己的阶层，武士阶层。所以这就是武士作为统治精英的概念在日本开始非常牢固地扎根的地方。赖朝实际上在京都传达了这个信息，然后他回到了镰仓，把古都留在了身后。这对京都来说是一种巨大的侮辱，但是，你知道，那里的每个人都必须忍受。
Remind me, who is the emperor at this point? Who is the actual emperor? Well, it's this little boy Gotoba, who finally, you know, they've got the regalia back, and so he's been crowned as emperor, but he's still kind of seven or something at this point, so not really a player. Yorotomo does not press to be given a kind of an official title at this point.
提醒我，此时的天皇是谁？真正的天皇是谁？嗯，是这个小男孩后鸟羽天皇，最后，你知道，他们拿回了神器，所以他被加冕为天皇，但他此时才七岁左右，所以并不是真正的参与者。赖朝此时并没有急于获得某种官方头衔。
He waits for Go Shirikawa to die and Go Shirikawa finally dies in the spring of 1192. And so Go-Toba, this little boy, is now, you know, he no longer has his grandfather kind of operating behind the scenes. So he's much easier for Yorotomo to influence. And so Yorotomo leans on the little boy, Go-Toba, the emperor, very heavily. And on the 21st of August 1192, Yoritomo is formally appointed Shogun. And of course, this is a title that means general, but general goes and fights barbarians,
他等待后白河去世，后白河最终在1192年春天去世。所以后鸟羽，这个小男孩，现在，你知道，他不再有他的祖父在幕后操纵了。所以他更容易受到赖朝的影响。于是赖朝非常沉重地向小男孩、天皇后鸟羽施压。1192年8月21日，赖朝被正式任命为征夷大将军。当然，这是一个意味着将军的头衔，但将军去战斗蛮族，
all that kind of thing. But it clearly now has a much deeper and richer resonance. You might compare it to Cromwell's title of Lord Protector, or you might compare it to the title of Imperator, the name of Imperator, that Augustus is given. And I think that there is a kind of parallel there because just as Augustus establishes an autocracy disguised in the kind of the robes of the Republic, Yorotomo is establishing a military autocracy kind of veiled in the ropes of the old imperial state.
所有那种事情。但它现在显然有了更深、更丰富的共鸣。你可以把它比作克伦威尔的“护国公”头衔，或者你可以把它比作奥古斯都获得的“皇帝”头衔。我认为这里有一种相似之处，因为正如奥古斯都建立了一个伪装在共和国长袍下的独裁统治，赖朝正在建立一个披着旧帝国国家长袍的军事独裁统治。
The emperor is still on the throne, but he's now completely neutralized. And the regime that Yorotomo establishes is very clearly a new beginning for Japan. And it is called by people a Bakufu, which is literally a government-ru, run from the headquarters of a general, the kind of the tent that a general has on maneuvers. This is what Japan has now become. And so Kyoto endures as the home of ritual, of tradition of the imperial family, but Kamakura is now the kind of indisputed center of government. And again, another parallel from Roman history, Kyoto is Rome, Kamakura is Constantinople.
天皇仍然在位，但他现在被完全中和了。赖朝建立的政权非常清楚地是日本的一个新开始。人们称之为“幕府”，字面意思是，从将军的总部运行的政府，就像将军在演习时拥有的帐篷。这就是日本现在所变成的样子。所以京都作为仪式、传统和皇室的家园而存在，但镰仓现在是无可争议的政府中心。同样，罗马历史上的另一个相似之处，京都就是罗马，镰仓就是君士坦丁堡。
Yeah, because the shogunate is where it's all at now. So the shogunate dispenses, influence, patronage, power and so on. And that endures, so you mentioned Augustus. I mean, the thing about Augustus is that the structure he creates endures after his death, which people didn't necessarily expect. But that's also the case with Yorotomo as well, isn't it? Because basically what he's built is resilient enough that it doesn't depend on his personal cunning and charisma and whatnot. Yeah.
是的，因为幕府现在是所有事情的核心。所以幕府分发影响力、恩惠、权力等等。而且它持续存在，所以你提到了奥古斯都。我的意思是，关于奥古斯都的事情是，他创造的结构在他死后持续存在，这是人们不一定预料到的。但这对于赖朝来说也是如此，不是吗？因为基本上他所建立的东西足够有弹性，以至于它不依赖于他个人的狡猾和魅力等等。是的。
So he died in 1199, 15 years after the end of the Civil War, he fell from his whole. horse, but everything that he constructed basically remains in place. So Kamakura stays as the center of government. The country is essentially united under the rule of the shogunate, across Honshu, across Kushu, across Shikoku, across Sashima. It is the samurai who are the local bigwigs. They hold the reins of power. And their rule really kind of beds down. And I think even more than Tokugawa Yasu, the guy who establishes the shokanate and its kind of very stratified form in the early 17th century, Yorotomo is the greatest political figure in samurai history. I mean, he is the guy who really establishes samurai rule and it will endure for century after century after century. And I think that
所以他在1199年去世，也就是内战结束15年后，他从马上摔了下来，但他所构建的一切基本上都保持原样。所以镰仓保持为政府中心。国家基本上在幕府的统治下统一，跨越本州、九州、四国、佐渡。是武士成为了当地的大人物。他们掌握着权力的缰绳。他们的统治确实扎根了。而且我认为甚至比德川家康，那个在17世纪初建立幕府及其分层形式的人，赖朝是武士历史上最伟大的政治人物。我的意思是，他是真正建立武士统治的人，它将持续几个世纪又几个世纪。而且我认为
this is becoming clear to the people in Japan in the decades following his death. Yes, because a great test lies ahead for Japan, doesn't it? And this takes us back to the very beginning of this series. to your own experience of video games. So, what are we? Maybe seven decades after the death of Yoritomo. So the system he is built is pretty resilient. But the great test is coming because we get to the year 1274 and the scene with which we began.
这在赖朝死后的几十年里正变得对日本人民清晰起来。是的，因为日本前方有一个巨大的考验，不是吗？这把我们带回了这个系列的开头。回到你自己的电子游戏体验。所以，我们现在是什么时候？也许是赖朝死后七十年。所以他建立的系统相当有弹性。但巨大的考验即将到来，因为我们到了1274年，也就是我们开始时的场景。
The island of Tsushima, the samurai who stand guard over the island looking out at the northern horizon and they see something absolutely mind-blowing. They see the arrival of this flea. more enormous and more terrifying than anything they could have believed possible. It is, of course, the fleet of the Mongols. So how will the samurai fare?
对马岛，守卫岛屿的武士看着北方的地平线，他们看到了绝对令人震惊的事情。他们看到了这支舰队的到来。比他们所能相信的任何东西都要巨大和恐怖。当然，这就是蒙古人的舰队。那么武士们会表现如何呢？
Tom, are you going to do that story right now? Or are you going to make us wait? You're going to make us wait, unbelievable. I'm going to do it probably later in the air, the story of the Mongol attack on Japan, the kamikaze, did it really happen, tremendous drama. one of the great narratives of Asian history. Great story. And of course, members of our Restis History Club will be able to hear all that story in one go when it finally, when you finally get around to doing it.
汤姆，你现在要讲那个故事吗？还是你要让我们等？你要让我们等，难以置信。我可能会在今年晚些时候讲，关于蒙古入侵日本的故事，神风，它真的发生了吗，巨大的戏剧性。亚洲历史上最伟大的叙事之一。伟大的故事。当然，我们历史俱乐部的成员将能够在它最终，当你最终有时间讲它时，一次性听到整个故事。
So that's something to look forward to. Now, what have we got coming up? We have coming up next week of complete and utter change of mood and pace as we return to 1970s Britain. So we'll be back with fan favorites Harold Wilson and James Callahan for the rock. of Margaret Thatcher. So Britain's first ever referendum, the decision to remain in the European community. Let's see how that worked out.
所以这很值得期待。那么，接下来我们要讲什么呢？下周我们将迎来完全不同的氛围和节奏，我们将回到20世纪70年代的英国。我们将带大家重温深受粉丝喜爱的哈罗德·威尔逊和詹姆斯·卡拉汉，以及玛格丽特·撒切尔的崛起。还有英国历史上第一次全民公投，关于留在欧洲共同体的决定。让我们看看结果如何。
Britain going bankrupt and having to get a bailout from the International Monetary Fund and all kinds of amusingly seedy and shabby 70s antics. So members of the Restis History Club will be able to get all of that series on Monday. That's exciting. So you get the whole thing. And if you want to get the whole thing on Monday,
英国濒临破产，不得不向国际货币基金组织寻求救助，以及各种70年代令人捧腹的卑劣和破败的闹剧。因此，历史俱乐部（Rest is History Club）的成员周一就能收听整个系列节目。这太令人兴奋了。你可以一次性听完。如果你想在周一获得全部内容，
all four episodes, you just have to sign up at the rest is history.com. You also get the fantastic new newsletter with all sorts of information about samurai and the 70s and all sorts. And you get a host of, I think the technical term is unbelievable benefits, isn't it, Tom? Yeah, unbelievable additional benefits, I think. Additional benefits. Additional benefits. On top of the benefits you're already getting. That was an epic journey, Tom. So, Aligathogazamos to you, Tom, and Adagata Zamas, everybody. And we we will see you next week for the 70s. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
全部四集，你只需要在therestisistory.com注册即可。你还能收到精彩的新通讯，里面有关于武士、70年代以及各种各样的信息。而且你还能获得一系列——我想专业术语叫“难以置信的福利”，对吧，汤姆？是的，我想是“难以置信的额外福利”。额外福利。额外福利。在你已经享受的福利之上。这是一段史诗般的旅程，汤姆。那么，汤姆，向你致敬，也向大家致敬。我们下周再见，一起聊聊70年代。再见。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。